Okay, so I can see how
the Firebase database is a better
choice than other data
options out there.
But are there other features that
are part of the platform that
are a good fit for
shopping list plus plus?
>> Well, knowing what you want
to do with your application.
Here are the top reasons why I
think you should use Firebase.
Data that is available in real time, so
users all get updated
shopping lists on demand.
So if Walter adds some
items on a shopping list,
you'll see these immediately.
Synchronization handled by the client.
Regardless if the client is online or
offline.
This ensures that clients that were
turned off or maybe in airplane mode
get the freshest copy of the data
possible when they come back online.
This is also helpful because you can
still add items to your shopping list
when you're offline and
have those changes available to
Walter when you're back online.
Easy to implement
authentication methods,
all without writing a lot of clients.
With this, Walter can use e-mail and
password or
his Google Plus account to log on.
Well in addition to what
we've talked about,
another benefit is Firebase's
two tier approach.
Many applications use
a three tier approach
where the middle tier contains business
logic or some application server.
But this introduces complexity and
system management issues.
For shopping list plus plus,
it's not necessary.
Instead, with Firebase you
use a two tier approach.
Basically, this is a client server model
where you communicate directly with
the database.
It's cheaper, easier to maintain,
quicker set up and
in the case of Firebase,
highly performant.
>> All right,
that sounds pretty good to me.
Although I do have one more request.
Do you happen to know any developers
that are actually using Firebase?
>> Sure I've actually got
a Firebase developer advocate
here with me right now.
>> Well, shoot.
I'm a bit busy getting our first
user set up with the app but
the developer has some free time.
Maybe they could join you.
>> Sure.
That'd be great.
>> Hey, if you want,
you can take the company skateboard.